right yeah first one for me stranger
things cosplayers around I I'm sure
there are a bunch I would imagine
there's some good sailor outfits what I
have not walked through yet maybe after
this have although people are very
attached to your haircut
sure yeah did you expect the the
reaction you showed up with the bangs on
the carpet and people were like what
happened to Steve Harrington's hair is
it coming back yeah you know it's just a
regular person getting a haircut
okay now this is the first we're really
learning about what this movie is all
about so recap the panel for me
what what's movie about sure I'm not
actually sure how much I can say I mean
I guess I can tell you it's about like
Ryan Reynolds plays this character in a
video game who's NPC like a non playable
character in the background of the game
it's kind of him slowly becoming you
know conscious and sort of realizing the
world he lives in so funny are you are
you a gamer not a huge gamer I mean I've
done as a kid I'd play games but I play
that game civilization here again it's
just like a pretty nerdy basic game it's
really fun yeah Grand Theft Auto kids so
yeah my mom didn't let me I couldn't you
know I'm like in middle school your
money back yeah okay so tell me about
who's your care sure i play keys and one
of the guys who is one of the designers
at the game and i work at the company
that take his character owns and
you can tell you can you can see my
spoiler training right now I feel like
I'm like going through my head like what
can I say what can I know it's my
strangest thing spoiler training
yeah that's I'll leave it at that for
now what was it like working in tandem
with taiga because he's one of my
favorite here yeah he's amazing so I
really respect him as a director and as
an actor and it you know I to be frankly
I was pretty nervous honestly showing up
first day but he's just like such a warm
guy who so many ideas and so many he's
just so charismatic and it's just really
confection so the the mood on set that
Shawn sets is very relaxed very
collaborative and he just came in and
just you know right in the fold
you know everybody was pretty
comfortable and felt comfortable trying
new ideas and have really collaborative
and for a movie that's this scale I
never thought that it would be so
collaborative obviously you and Shawn go
back we just got a teaser yeah beats me
you think they tell me anything I don't
know anything yeah I may be bits and
pieces here and there but they keep it
pretty close to the chest just because
you know they're the writing and
developing the ideas and you know I I
I've heard rumors but nothing that is
worth confirming or denying or getting
anyone excited about shooting no I don't
think we'll start for a while yeah
thanks so much
you